blink once if you die blink twice if you  live stare straight ahead question let's  question are you excited to finally see  this because the the brothers told us  that they you there they give you a  limited script that's right yeah  I'm excited to see it I can't believe  today is here finally that I'm gonna get  to see this thing I woke up this morning  it was like Christmas  well they got excited it's happening  today finally alright SNL what can you  tell us about us to know how are we  excited how excited are you about that  ly excited about that season finale I've  hosted it just with my fourth time  hosting and it's terrifying every time  but really exciting and I'm looking  forward to that  that's rarefied air for times you're  creeping up on the rock and those guys  I'm one away from the jacket yeah yeah I  got to get to that exclusive club  [Music]  [Applause]